er Verantwortung nicht teilen sondern
einfach weiter schieben das macht jetzt
auch Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
im ARD morgen bei der Magazin sagt er
jetzt die Schulschließungen hätte man
vermeiden können wir Wissensstand sei
nicht gut genug gewesen die Wissenschaft
hätte die Politik falsch beraten damit
griff er den Charité Virologen Christian
Drosten an der wiederum hat kommt
zurückgeschossen für die
Schulschließungen sei nicht eher
verantwortlich gewesen dieser Fehler
liege eindeutig bei der Politik eines
steht also fest die monatelange
Schulschließungen die bei Kindern und in
der Gesellschaft insgesamt massive
Schäden hinterlassen haben waren
komplett unnötig Kindern wurde Schulzeit
und Lebenszeit geraubt sie saßen allein
zu Hause hatten keinen Kontakt zu
Freunden getroffen hat es dann vor allem
Kinder aus sozial schwächeren Familien
Kindern bei denen die Eltern eben nicht
helfen konnten beim Lernstoff die wurden
abgehängt Psychologen berichten auch von
Missbrauch von Gewalt Lehrer verloren
einfach jeden Kontakt zu ihren Schülern
und jetzt schieben sich die Verantwort
gegenseitig die Schuld in die Schuhe
kritiker fordern Konsequenzen bis hin
zum sofortigen Rücktritt von Karl
lauterbracht Herr Frau Hermann erleben
wir da so eine Art Rückzugsgefecht
keiner will es am Ende gewesen sein aber
das ist ja immer so das ist gar nicht
neu und gar nicht überraschend natürlich
versucht jetzt ja Lauterbach sich
herauszureden so wie Herr Spahn
versuchte sich herauszureden so wie
andere sich versuchen heraus zu reden am
Anfang war die Lage ja auch etwas
unübersichtlich das will ich gerne
konzentrieren im Frühjahr 220 wusste
keiner so richtig womit wir es zu tun
haben wie das alles ausgehen würde und
was zu tun ist da kann man das Store mit
der Stange im Nebel noch nachvollziehen
aber es wurde ja dann immer klarer und
immer dichter dann hat man gemerkt dass
das mit den Masken so nicht funktioniert
und so weiter man hätte also ziemlich
schnell wieder zu anderen Maßnahmen
kommen können bzw Maßnahmen eben beenden
können es gab Eltern die hatten Angst
ihre Kinder könnten sich infizieren dann
hätten die überlegen können ob Sie die
Kinder Unternehmen für eine Weile aber
man hätte die Schulen nicht schließen
müssen und das hat man daran erkannt das
ist diese ganzen tollen Geräte gab die
die Eltern auch in unserer Schule
gespendet haben um die Luft eben
sozusagen immer zu reinigen in den
Klassenzimmern die gar nicht zum Einsatz
gekommen sind also irgendwann war das
alles nicht mehr schlüssig und dann hat
die Politik eben immer das Problem
zuzugeben ganz ehrlich zuzugeben ja das
haben wir nicht richtig einschätzen
können ich glaube wir brauchen das jetzt
nicht mehr würden das jetzt wieder und
so weiter das geht dann nicht es kann
sich keiner entschuldigen es kann keiner
sagen nach dem damaligen Stand des
Wissens haben wir so gemacht aber jetzt
können wir es anders machen und vor
allem geht es auch Herr Dorndorf darum
Verantwortung zu übernehmen können Sie
die Wut der Bürger nachvollziehen jetzt
kommen immer mehr Sachen ans Licht die
Kritiker schon damals angemerkt haben
besonders auch bei den Kindern viele
fordern auch Rücktritte auch von ihrem
Parteikollegen entspannen ja also das
Problem ist ja dass wir insgesamt ja
eine Zeit haben wo die Politik ja so
nicht richtig ja vertraut wird und das
sind natürlich Punkte das was sie gerade
gesagt haben dass man dann auch mal
Verantwortung übernimmt und für viele
einsteht was in der Familie in der Firma
über einen normalen menschlich ist was
ganz normal wäre das trifft man leider
in der Politik nicht dann wenn man immer
alles schön reden und das ist halt ein
Punkt der jetzt hoch kommt der natürlich
zur Politikverdrossenheit noch stärker
kommt und damit macht man die Rechte und
linken Lager eigentlich wieder stark und
das ist halt schade die großen Verlierer
auf einmal sind die Kinder aus sie sind
Familienvater wir haben sie diese Zeit
erlebt jetzt wissen wir beispielsweise
auch dass viele Virologen auch die
maskenpflicht hinterfragen wie
beispielsweise Jonas Schmidt kann er
sieht der sagt die allgemeine
maskenpflicht hat gar nicht so viel
gebracht und die Kinder bei den Geist ja
besonders streng wenn alle im Büro schon
wieder ohne Maske waren alle in der
Schule noch mit Maske gegen ihren
Kindern und dieses Gefühl da Lebenszeit
verloren ja ich glaube das war auf jeden
Fall definitiv über die Stränge
geschlagen das hat er auch einen anderen
Ländern wie Schweden gezeigt dass es gar
nicht so strenge Maßnahmen braucht und
jetzt hat man halt herausgefunden dass
es wirklich einfach überspitzt war
wieder gehandelt wurde und gerade auf
Kosten der Kinder meine Kinder hatten
dann nie ein Problem mit der Maske die
waren aber einfach heilfroh als er
endlich wieder ihren Lehrer oder
Lehrerin ins Gesicht schauen konnte oder
die Hälfte verdeckt zu haben und selber
einfach wieder komplett frei atmen zu
können das war so ein großes ja so ein
loslassenes Stein vom Herzen und vom
Rücken gefallen aber ich kann jetzt
nicht sagen dass unsere Kinder vom Maske
tragen irgendwelche Schäden hatten ich
glaube dass da einfach wirklich Fehler
gemacht worden und das sollte man heute
auch zugeben und dann in Zukunft falls
das noch mal passiert es wird
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal eine Partie
Pandemie geben anders handeln Fehler
zugeben es ist Stichwort herrjenige
Fehler zugeben können das Politiker
einfach nicht nein ich glaube die waren
alle am Anfang total überfordert was ich
auch verstehen kann ich habe die keine
Sekunde beneidet um das Handling dieser
Pandemie das war auch neu es gibt Blende
die man noch strenger als wir als
Beispiel Neuseeland das haben die
meisten Länder sehr ähnlich agiert also
die Amerikaner sowieso dabei auch oder
was da durften nicht mal mehr die
Strände gehen insofern finde ich jetzt
ein bisschen einfach zu sagen ja das
hättet ihr alles anders machen können
das war eine völlig neue Situation die
haben es glaube ich so gut gemeint wie
es geht selbst die Virologen waren sich
alle uneinig das ist auch schwer da die
richtigen Entscheidung treffen
der letzte der sagt jetzt sollen die da
alle mal zurücktreten ich denke wir
sollten was Ravi Sachen die Zukunft
denken was ist wenn es wieder passiert
jemand wie Bill Gates glaubt ja dass die
nächste Pandemie bereits wartet einfach
überlegen wie gehen wir in Zukunft mit
solchen Katastrophen aber da wäre sehr
wichtig noch mal einen Punkt zu klären
wir haben es anhand der Kinder
besprochen die sich am wenigsten werden
können wenn Zwangsmaßnahmen kommen aber
die Art und Weise wie zum Beispiel
ungeimpfte beschimpft worden sind
öffentlich von Politikern im Fernsehen
die man mit asozialen Leuten in
Zusammenhang gebracht hat die man
wegsperren wollte die ihre Bürgerrechte
verwirken sollten in bestimmten
Bereichen das hat ein inneres vibrieren
in dieser Regierung zu Tage gebracht
oder auch in den Landesregierungen dass
mich persönlich sehr verstimmt hat als
Bürgerrechtlerin weil ich das Gefühl
hatte dass man da das Kind mit dem
badeausschüttet und übertreibt und das
kann jetzt jederzeit wieder passieren
wenn also so viele Politiker so drauf
sogar da wird der Zwangsmaßnahme
verhängt und das Volk kann gerne reden
wie es will interessiert mich nicht das
halte ich für bedenklich und das sollte
man noch mal gründlicher hinschauen und
verhindern dass sowas in Zukunft wieder
geschickt oder der Vertrauen verspielt
er
das ist kein neues Thema was ich viel
trauriger finde ich weiß zufällig dass
die ganzen jugendpsychiatrien an den
Unikliniken waren völlig überlastet
Leute haben zehn Monate einen Termin ich
glaube solche Dinge sollten wir reden
gibt es gibt eine ausreichende
Versorgung für Kinder die in Not sind
oder Jugendliche also ich finde dass
dieses mit dem Finger auf Leute zeigen
ehrlich gesagt ohne konstruktive lieber
überlegen wie wir das in Zukunft besser
aufstellen organisieren können und wie
können wir auch aus den Fehlern lernen
und wie können wir die Jugendlichen und
insbesondere die Kinder die eben
besonders gelitten haben unter dieser
Pandemie jetzt unterstützen und ich
kenne da auch viele Fälle die heute eben
noch drunter leiden und da ist kein
Support da und da muss auch der Staat
eingreifen und sagen hey wir stellen da
noch mehr Menschen ein die sich um
Kinder kümmern den es heute nicht so gut
die nicht so gut geht und die besonders
und dann Pandemie dieser Satz den sie
auch gesagt haben man musste es
natürlich damals nicht besser das hilft
Kindern die bis heute leiden oder auch
in ihrer Branche Künstler die keine
Engagements mehr bekommen haben der
Flieger war voll das Theater war leer
die Pleite gegangen Existenzen ist
natürlich ein bisschen die Frage
Systemrelevanz es wurde halt die
Lufthansa Geräte die TUI gerettet das
wurden ja sehr interessante große
Autokonzerne wurden gerettet weil Kultur
ist nicht systemrelevant Jugendliche
Kinder sind ich glaube die
Prioritätenliste sollte gründlichen
Frage gestellt werden und ich glaube wir
müssen aber erst mal sagen was heißt das
alles für soziale Konsequenzen für Leute
die eben jetzt nicht bei der TUI oder
bei Lufthansa arbeiten muss mit ihm
nicht vielleicht anders auffangen und da
ist sie natürlich Fehler gemacht worden
sind die Franzosen sich besser gehandelt
da kann man auch ich finde meins aus
dann gucken wir haben das andere Länder
gemacht und ich glaube da kann man wenn
man sich mal so allgemein umschaut
kommen immer von anderen lernen hätten
wir vielleicht aber auch früher machen
können oder im Ausland wurde das doch
teilweise ganz anders geregelt der saßen
die Kinder nicht so lange im Lockdown
ist es geht ja für eine Pflege Reform
das gilt für eine Frage es geht für eine
verkehrsreform es gibt davon geheilt
weil wir halt zögerlich sind
damit ist nein das kannst Du
verbotskulturen also ich mir das dann
darf nicht vorausgreifen aber die USA
sind noch nicht untergegangen wurde seit
50 Jahren Tempolimit haben das Land
gibt's noch und nach Holland fährt
langsam das gibt's auch noch und die
Skandinavien sind auch noch nicht
Untergang also wir haben ja auch eine
unfassbare Angst vor verboten die ich
nicht so ganz verstehe aber ich würde
das noch mal aufgenommen hat weil ich
das auch in meiner Heimat halt sehe dass
viele Jugendliche Schüler echte Probleme
haben die gehen zurzeit nicht zur Schule
und man weiß gar nicht was ist da
eigentlich los und in der Schule ich
habe es jetzt gerade gesehen bei meiner
Tochter ich habe eine 14 oder jetzt
15-jährige Tochter da haben sich zum
Glück die die Lehrerin
zusammengeschlossen und hat also vier
fünf Kinder die Probleme haben also
reden ähm zusammengeführt davon haben
wir viel zu wenig es wird einfach jetzt
der nächste Schritt gemacht und diese
Kinder werden einfach vergessen und das
ist ganz schlecht aber die kommen
alleine nicht auf die Beine das muss man
einfach ganz klar sagen er war auch die
Eltern gar nicht im Stande manchmal sind
sie arbeiten
brauchen wir neue anfange dann sind sind
sie dafür dass Lauterbach zurück
dieser Rücktritt also es wird immer so
schnell gefordert von Politikern ich
finde jeder kann Fehler machen das ist
einfach so wenn ich in meinem Betrieb
Fehler mache bin seit 36 Jahren
selbstständig dann trete ich nicht
zurück sondern versuche diesen Fehler
nicht noch mal zu machen und versuchen
nach Lösungen zu finden und darum finde
ich rücktrittsgesuche und versuche immer
immer schlecht sage ich mal die bringen
uns ja nicht weiter dann kommt der
nächste den Posten wir ja keiner mehr
haben das sind ja Schleudersitze man
muss auch mal die Leute die Politik mal
stärken dass sie auch mal Fehler machen
dürfen das ist ja das andere Problem
aber hier müssen wir auf jeden Fall
einschreiten und wir haben keine Lehrer
und das die können wir uns den schnitzen
und das ist einfach nicht da und da muss
man andere Wege gehen es gibt der Art
verwandte Berufe wo wir den Einstieg
viel leichter machen müssen das ist
immer noch viel zu kompliziert ist doch
viel einfacher wenn ich jemand habe der
Arzt verwandt ist der dann die Kinder
betreut als wenn ich gar keine Betreuung
habe und sie alleine lassen insofern ist
eine riesen Aufgabe und dann müssen wir
sehr viele Gesetze Veränderung
durchführen und verschlanken vor allen
Dingen aber ich würde auch härter
durchgreifen also wir haben jetzt in
Sachsen die Debatte und ich finde zu
Recht dass die Lehrer die da Freistadt
Sachsen hat bitte auch falsch Vollzeit
arbeiten sollen es gibt viele die
teilzeitarbeiten damit sie in der
Großstadt bleiben können damit sie nicht
aufs Land raus müssen das ist natürlich
eine Vermeidungsstrategie die ist
komfortabel für den Lehrer der das macht
Politik bleiben denn jetzt haben wir
gerade gehört man muss da auch mal
einfach weitermachen können man muss da
nach vorne schauen
also das tut mir leid das Konzept von
Reue und Vergebung besteht darin dass
man erstmal einsieht das sind Fehler
passiert ist dass finde ich nicht in
Ordnung
ja das geht finde ich kulturell nicht
auf und dann kommt der zweite Sache
hinzu die gerne mal weggeblendet wird es
gibt ganz viele Fragen im Medizin und im
medizinischen Bereich die ungelöst sind
es wurden Krankenhäuser geschlossen es
muss überlegt werden wie in der Fläche
mit Krankenhäusern umgegangen wird die
eben keine spezialkrankenhäuser für
Herzkrankheiten sein können sondern
maximal eine bessere Schwesternstation
also das muss man alles neu ordnen und
da hat er Lauterbach einfach drei Jahre
zwei Jahre nichts gemacht und man hat
also ein großes Resort er hat sich auf
ein Thema kapriziert mit war dann
gefühlt jeden Abend in der Talkshow und
das war seine Arbeit das mag für ihn
persönliche interessant gewesen sein
aber ich finde da gehört deutlich mehr
dazu zum Beispiel auch zu verhindern
dass eben bestimmte Medikamente hier zum
Engpass werden weil eben schon vor
Jahren diese Produktion nach Indien
ausgelagert worden ist sie selbst
vorher schon viel es gelten eigentlich
ist alles in Ordnung jeder hat das alles
von seinen Vorgängern das ist in Ordnung
aber die 100 Tage sind die 100 Tage und
dann beginnt das Amt sie saßen selbst
lange im Bundestag für die Grünen kann
sich ein Politiker nicht entschuldigen
ist man dann quasi ruiniert
innerhalb der eigenen Truppe sehr oft
also jeder ist immer genug Leute die
auch gerne nachstoßen und den Ämter
kommen möchten und dann wird das genutzt
natürlich ist das so aber das Problem
ist wenn es keine Fehler Kultur in der
leitungseben in der Politik gibt wo
sollen dann die Fehler Korrektur bei den
Leuten in den ganzen Berufen herkommen
also wenn schlechte Beispiele gibt dann
werden die genutzt und haben alle
anderen auch eine Ausrede ich finde das
nicht richtig wir sollten viel ehrlich
damit miteinander reden